ya estuvimos hablando sobre los
hidrocarburos y dijimos que los
hidrocarburos son muy interesantes
especialmente si los usamos como
combustibles pero ahora las cosas se
pondrán más interesantes al agregarles
algunas otras cosas a eso que
agregaremos les llamaremos grupos
funcionales grupos funcionales mi
objetivo en este vídeo es darles un
repaso de los grupos funcionales más
comunes que se pueden encontrar unidos a
las cadenas de carbonos haciendo que las
moléculas sean más interesantes
biológicamente el primero que me
gustaría mostrarles es el grupo h aquí
tenemos un h unido a una cadena de
carbonos a este h se le conoce como
grupo hidroxilo hidroxilo y cuando está
unido a una cadena de carbonos como esta
y lo h convierte a toda la molécula en
un alcohol
qué es un alcohol y por si quieren saber
el nombre como esta molécula tiene dos
carbonos y es un alcohol tiene el
prefijo & vamos a escribirlo
por los dos carbonos primero escribimos
el prefijo ed porque tenemos dos
carbonos y el nombre completo es etanol
ok
dentro de las propiedades como aquí
tenemos un oxígeno que es muy electro
negativo unido a un hidrógeno y un
carbono como el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno aquí tenemos
una carga parcial negativa y en el
hidrógeno tenemos una carga parcial
positiva también tenemos una en el
carbono pero como el hidrógeno es menos
electro negativo que el carbono podemos
decir que un grupo hidroxilo es polar y
como es polar lo podemos disolver en
agua es hidrofílico puede formar puentes
de hidrógeno
y algo similar ocurre con el grupo
funcional que tenemos aquí aunque tal
vez se pregunte hoy es que es similar
aquí sí tenemos azufre en lugar de
oxígeno bueno si observamos la tabla
periódica veremos que el azufre y el
oxígeno tienen 6 electrones de valencia
y les encanta tener electrones por eso
tienden a formar dos enlaces covalentes
a este grupo se le conoce como grupo
sulfhídrico sulfhídrico este es un grupo
muy parecido al grupo hidroxilo con la
diferencia de que el azufre es electro
negativo pero no tan electro negativo
como el oxígeno y también tenemos una
carga parcial negativa y una carga
parcial positiva solo que esto no es tan
polar como el grupo hidroxilo ahora
cuando tenemos un grupo sulfhídrico
unido a una cadena de carbonos cuando
tenemos una r aquí significa que tenemos
una cadena de carbonos y otras cosas
ejemplo si queremos generalizar un
alcohol podemos escribir r y después el
grupo hidroxilo o unido a una h en este
caso la letra r corresponde a todo esto
entonces esta r puede que no sea igual a
esto pero corresponde a una cadena de
carbonos ya sea solo de carbonos e
hidrógeno o incluso puede ser una que
contenga a otros grupos funcionales pero
vamos a enfocarnos en el grupo
sulfhídrico si ven algo como esto pueden
decir ok esto será polar pero no tan
polar como un grupo hidroxilo ahora de
este lado tenemos una molécula más
compleja pero muy común esta molécula es
azúcar fructosa
fructosa
esta es la fructosa cuando no tiene la
forma de un anillo si la ponemos en agua
fácilmente formará un anillo pero si no
podemos reconocer fácilmente los grupos
hidroxilo en este carbono tenemos un
grupo hidroxilo en este carbono también
tenemos un grupo hidroxilo en este
carbono grupo hidroxilo grupo hidroxilo
otro grupo hidroxilo en este carbono
pero este carbono que está unido con un
doble enlace a un oxígeno es un grupo
carbon hilo
este es un grupo carbón hilo carbón hilo
entonces en la cadena de carbonos del
azúcar todos los carbonos tienen un
grupo hidroxilo excepto este que tiene
un grupo carbon hilo y en este grupo
bueno ya dijimos que el oxígeno es más
electro negativo que el carbono así que
tenemos una carga parcial negativa aquí
y por acá tenemos una carga parcial
positiva
entonces esto también es polar en
realidad toda la molécula es polar
debido a los grupos hidroxilo pero esto
también tiene polaridad y como este
carbono tiene una carga parcial positiva
se encuentra disponible para un ataque
núcleo físico cuando estudian química
orgánica encontrarán cosas que pueden
compartir sus electrones por medio de
enlaces así que querrán formar un enlace
covalente con este carbono y tal vez uno
de esos pares de electrones se mueva
hacia el oxígeno pero hablaremos más
sobre eso cuando estudiemos los
mecanismos en química orgánica aquí lo
importante es que tenemos varios grupos
hidroxilo y un grupo carbón y lo ahora
esta molécula es un aminoácido se
encontrarán con muchos aminoácidos al
estudiar biología este en particular
tiene varias cosas muy interesantes
miren aquí tenemos un grupo muy
interesante
este es un carbono que podríamos pensar
que es parte de un grupo carbón hilo
pero también está unido a un grupo
hidroxilo cuando tenemos un carbono
unido con un doble enlace a un oxígeno y
después unido con un enlace simple a un
grupo hidroxilo entonces es un grupo car
box y lo este es un grupo car box y lo y
una de las propiedades de este grupo es
que es un ácido porque puede donar un
hidrógeno como al oxígeno le gusta
acaparar electrones puede quedarse con
los dos electrones y ser negativo y por
acá puede haber resonancia porque los
electrones se pueden mover en todo el
grupo dejando afuera al hidrógeno así
que esto puede donar un protón y por eso
se dice que es ácido
para el aminoácido la parte ácido se
refiere al grupo car box y los pero
también tenemos un grupo amino este es
un grupo amino y contiene un nitrógeno
este es el grupo amino por eso toda la
molécula es un aminoácido y bueno esta
es una forma general porque en realidad
el nitrógeno tiene un par de electrones
libres por aquí y este par de electrones
puede formar un enlace con otro
hidrógeno que se encuentre como unión
hidrógeno que sea unión positivo es
decir un protón así que tiene una carga
positiva pero bueno quitemos el guión
para que sólo tengamos una mina básica
toda esta molécula se llama leucina es
un aminoácido muy importante para el
crecimiento de los músculos y podemos
ver que consiste en una cadena de
carbonos un grupo car box y lo y un
grupo amino pero por ejemplo
si nos enfocamos en la parte conformada
por hidrocarburos la cadena principal
puede empezar ya sea en este carbono o
este supongamos que esta es la cadena
principal de carbonos si esta es la
cadena principal podemos decir que este
es un grupo metilo recuerden el prefijo
mets se refiere a un carbono aquí
tenemos un carbono unido a tres
hidrógenos este es un grupo metilo y en
general cuando tenemos un carbono unido
a otros carbonos todo eso es hidrofóbico
aquí no hay polaridad así que estas
partes de la molécula no se disolverán
fácilmente en agua y finalmente el
último grupo que tenemos y que se
encontrarán mucho en biología que
sobretodo los podemos encontrar en el
atp y el adn son los grupos fosfato todo
esto corresponde al grupo fosfato en
este caso está unido a un grupo r que
pueden ser cadenas
de carbonos con otras cosas y por acá
está unido a todos hidrógenos no siempre
tiene que estar unido a dos hidrógenos
pero cuando está unido a hidrógeno se
dice que está protón ado así que el
oxígeno acapara los electrones y deja
los hidrógenos en la solución entonces
podemos decir que el grupo fosfato es un
ácido ácido especialmente cuando está
protón ado y se considera un ácido
porque puede donar protones este fue
sólo un repaso de algunos grupos
funcionales que veremos en biología
generalmente encontraremos moléculas muy
grandes y complejas pero al analizarlas
encontraremos cadenas de carbonos grupos
hidroxilo grupos carbón y los grupos
amino grupos cars box y lo y podremos
suponer que esto es ácido es polar y
veremos que las diferentes partes de las
moléculas consisten en diferentes grupos
funcionales